on va pas donner de la chloroquine à la
france entière donc de toutes façons les
indications de la chloroquine ça va pas
être 65 millions de français
on va pas en prendre au petit déjeuner
c'est pas des bonbons et la chloroquine
est une molécule très facile à faire je
ne pense vraiment pas qu'il y à une
pénurie possible chloroquine c'est une
molécule ancienne qu'on peut fabriquer
très vite en très grande quantité donc
le problème actuel c'est pas le stock de
chloroquine c'est pas du tout la même
chose que le le manque de masques c'est
simplement qu'on a une incertitude
encore sur le périmètre des gens à qui
il faut lé donné sur l'efficacité de la
molécule et je me permets de rajouter
que le ministre olivier derand il est
vraiment courageux de prendre les
positions qu'ils prennent dans
l'hystérie collective actuelle qui est
normal parce que nous sommes tous très
inquiète et bassano radio va contrario
de didier raoul t-notes remise de la
santé moi je sais pas pour le critiquer
créé la polémique il faut faire preuve
de cohésion nationale et d'unité dans le
contexte mais à parce que vous venez de
dire
didier raoult tu dis très clairement
faut le prendre au début du traitement
ou tout début déconnade et ce ne le
virus est là nous notre gouvernement
notre ministre a donné la possibilité de
le faire en réanimation
or la ati diarra hoult qui est quand
même celui qui nous fait cette
préconisation après ouais on a le droit
des sceptiques 1 c'est même lui le dit
dans le reportage on a le droit d'être
sceptique
en tout cas il dit en réanimation ça
n'aura pas d'effets ça ne sert à rien
c'est là où on me dit de l'eau prescrit
en france on est a contrario ne peut pas
faire or on perd on ne peut pas faire un
essai sur la base de l'avis du seul
professeur raoul tu des infectiologues
en a mille en france on peut pas écouter
uniquement king et ça le problème s'est
pas posé les problèmes mais on connaît
les périodes où ça s'arrête là mais
personne n'a dit qu'il fallait écouter
cas où tu sais rien
quand vous parlez de raout on dirait que
ce gars il est perché les seuls au monde
il ya une équipe c'est un des plus
grands centres de recherche d'europe il
ya chez de marseille c'est pas n'importe
quoi t'es pas n'importe qui il ya toute
une équipe derrière qui travaillent sur
ce sujet depuis des décennies mais 35 à
quoi travaillent sur ces question
d'épidémie
donc quand il dit la chloroquine donc on
la donne depuis des décennies
effectivement en podologie peut être
moindre et je propose que nous puissions
la donnée aux dés
dès qu'on a décelé le virus après des
électrocardiogrammes après des tests
pour prendre en compte les effets
secondaires et avec une posologie qu'il
est mesuré
voilà ce qu'ils disent on prend le
protocole qui préconise parce qu'il a
travaillé un laboratoire lui est pas
certaine qui le critiquent
soit on prend pas mais si on prend ce
qu'il dit et commande fait effectivement
qu'à ça à sa sauce et qu'on le donne en
réanimation alors que là on sait très
bien que ça n'aura pas d'effet c'est
quoi c'est qu'on veut plomber on veut
plomber la tête au raout on veut dire
qu'il adore docteur péronne je suis très
choqué par ce débat parce que la dame à
la fin que les des drogues six clubs qui
nous match no et l'étude de raout quand
même sur 80 patients montrent que la
chance de lire alors monsieur période on
a la pression sur l'ex monsieur
alexandre va vous répondre que ces
malades aurait été guérie
même son que rockin parce qu'ils ont la
bêtise c'est faux puisque on voit que la
charge virale baisse beaucoup plus
rapidement maintenant aux états unis la
fda a donné son autorisation
le ministère américain de 10 millions
d'euros dans tous les hôpitaux
américains disant allez-y pour traiter
tous les malades puisque la sévérité
l'italie des décrets ya plusieurs jours
pour dire ça y est tous les médecins
généralistes doivent donner libre cours
à toutes les mamans en fils
dans cette scientifique internationale
et que la france qui dit attendre les
résultats
je suis profondément choqué la marche ça
va moi je le vois dans mon hôpital je
vois partout le témoignage de l'europe
entière ça marche bien il ya quelques
intellectuels qui dit dans sa presse
d'éprouver la partie rotor entre classes
et moi pour voir ses enfants des
manchots quand on est dans une situation
de m on s'en fout des normes
internationales protocole c'est
profondément choquant les résultats il
ya tellement france
il ya encore quatre cents morts par jour
gouvernement totalement irresponsable
d'attendre encore on va attendre encore
une semaine deux semaines
combien de milliers de morts c'est
scandaleux